[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen guten
Abend Sven Voss ist bei mir übernimmt
später den sportlichen Teil der Sendung
auch von mir schönen guten Abend und das
haben wir heute unter anderem für Sie
vorbereitet
nach der panzerentscheidung
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
verspricht die Ausrüstung der Bundeswehr
schnell zu verbessern
Messerattacke im Regionalzug mutige
Passagiere stoppen den vorbestraften
Angreifer
und hackernetzwerk zerschlagen FBI und
deutsche Ermittler stoppen cyber-
[Musik]
nach der panzerentscheidung Deutschlands
und anderer Staaten stellt sich auch die
Frage ob das Risiko aktiv in den Krieg
hineingezogen zu werden gestiegen ist
der Kanzler sagt dazu nein der Kreml
sieht den Westen zunehmend als
Kriegspartei und die Ukraine fordert
inzwischen schon schwerere Waffen vom
Westen Thomas gonseer berichtet über den
Tag nach dem historischen Beschluss und
die jüngsten Angriffe auf die Ukraine
Krater Löcher und Wunden haben die
Geschosse gerissen nahe Kiew dort wo
Menschen zu Hause waren von landesweit
55 Raketen spricht die Ukraine und von
11 Toten
Russland schickt Raketen auch am Tag
nach der Entscheidung über
kampfpanzerlieferungen und schickt
Bilder von panzerabwehrsystemen sowie
von westlichen Leopard Panzern rechts
unten steht zahnlose Katzen Botschaft
keine Chance gegen russisches Gerät und
per Audio-Botschaft sagt Putins Sprecher
Peskow
alles was die Allianz und die westlichen
Hauptstädte tun wird in Moskau als
direkte Beteiligung am Konflikt
aufgefasst die Beteiligung wird größer
der Westen gar Deutschland eine
Kriegspartei nein wir sind keine
kriegsparteifer das Völkerrecht
eindeutige Regeln hat Konfliktpartei
werde ich erst wenn ich mit eigenen
Truppen in das Kampfgeschehen eingreife
auch der Kanzler betont gestern im ZDF
zur panzerentscheidung
ist Deutschland damit Kriegspartei nein
in keinem Fall und darum ging es auch zu
keiner Zeit auch nicht darum
Bodentruppen zu schicken oder
Kampfflugzeuge doch um die bittet nun
der Präsident der Ukraine gegenüber der
NATO
wir brauchen nun eine Freigabe für die
Lieferung von Langstreckenraketen und
die Lieferung von Kampfflugzeugen für
die Ukraine
was könnte es nun heißen dass es beim
Leopard bleibt das wahrscheinlichste
Szenario ist das Russland seine eigene
Offensive vorzieht um Geländegewinne zu
machen bevor dieser Kampfpanzer
überhaupt in der Ukraine auf dem
Schlachtfeld erscheint
überhaupt dass sich die Zerstörungen der
Krieg ausweiten könnten diese Angst im
Westen zum Militärexperten sei lange
schon eine wirksame Waffe Moskau
im Fokus der zeitenwände und den
jüngsten panzerbeschlüssen steht ganz
besonders der neue
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
heute gab es die erste Tuchfühlung
zwischen ihm und der Truppe in
Sachsen-Anhalt über den Besuch
materiallücken und Erwartungen an den
neuen berichtet Andreas Weise
am 7 Arbeitstag als
Verteidigungsminister der erste Besuch
bei der Truppe Boris Pistorius in
Altengrabow östlich von Magdeburg kaum
angekommen gleich die Frage eines
englischen Journalisten wann denn die
Leopard Panzer in der Ukraine sein
werden
zum Ende des ersten Quartals also Ende
März so der Minister
dann heißt es Gehörschutz auf es wird
scharf geschossen Angehörige eines
Logistikbataillons trainieren für den
Ernstfall
für den Kommandanten des
Truppenübungsplatzes ist der Besuch des
Ministers mit einer Hoffnung verbunden
wir haben hier seit Jahren den
mangelverwaltet
und ziel muss es sein wieder an eine
Vollausstattung heranzukommen Teil 2 des
Besuchs auf dem Truppenübungsplatz
Gefechtsschießen eines
Panzergrenadierbataillons die Puma
Schützenpanzer zuletzt vor allem durch
Ausfälle in den Schlagzeilen machen
heute keine Probleme trotzdem die
Weitergabe von Waffen und Ausrüstung an
die Ukraine jahrelange Mängel bei der
Beschaffung die Bundeswehr hat viele
Baustellen das weiß auch der Minister
deswegen ist die vorrangige Aufgabe
jetzt für mich mit der Rüstungsindustrie
die Gespräche aufzunehmen und dafür zu
sorgen dass die beschaffungszeiten
deutlich verkürzt werden da wo immer es
geht oder ausgeholfen wird mit Material
was dazu geeignet ist schon kommende
Woche soll es diese Gespräche geben
seinem ersten Besuch bei der Truppe
sollen viele weitere Folgen der neue
Bundesverteidigungsminister verspricht
dass er sein Ohr nah an der Truppe haben
will
die Spionageaffäre beim
Bundesnachrichtendienst weitet sich aus
nachdem im Dezember einen mutmaßlicher
Spion aufgeflogen war hat die
Bundesanwaltschaft einen möglichen
Komplizen festnehmen lassen er soll die
ausspionierten Geheiminformationen nach
Russland gebracht haben und kein BND
Mitarbeiter sein der Mann wurde am
Flughafen München gefasst ihm wird
Landesverrat vorgeworfen
17 und 19 Jahre so alt waren die
Todesopfer der Messerattacke in einem
Regionalzug gestern in
Schleswig-Holstein zudem wurden weitere
fünf Menschen verletzt zwei davon
lebensgefährlich der Angreifer ein
33-jähriger Palästinenser kam 2014 als
Flüchtling nach Deutschland und ist
Polizei bekannt warum ist zu dieser Blut
Tat kam ist noch völlig unklar Heike
Kruse berichtet
eine weiße Rose zum Gedenken an die
Opfer der Messe Attacke im
Regionalexpress von Kiel nach Hamburg
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer
kontrollierte dem
schleswig-holsteinischen
Ministerpräsidenten heute am Bahnhof
steht zwei Menschen starben dort gestern
eine 17-Jährige junge Frau und ein
19-jähriger Mann laut Augenzeugen
berichten war der mutmaßliche Täter mit
einem Messer durch den Zug gelaufen
die nur geschrieben haben hat Messer
laufen möglicherweise gerade den Bahnhof
eingefahren in dem Moment kam der
vermeintliche Messerstecher in unserem
Wagon
wollte die Treppe hoch mit der erhobener
Hand und dem Messer und da hat sich ein
Mitfahrer dem entgegengeschmissen bzw
den man Koffer gegengeschmissen außerdem
verletzte der mutmaßliche Täter zwei
Zugreisende lebensbedrohliche und drei
schwer es handelt sich um einen 33 Jahre
alten Staatenlosen Palästinenser gegen
ihn wurde inzwischen ein Haftbefehl
wegen Mordes und versuchten Totschlags
erlassen
Ibrahim a ist 2014 eingereist seit 2015
in Nordrhein-Westfalen und Hamburg
mehrfach straffällig geworden unter
anderem wegen dem Gewalt
zudem ist bekannt dass er zuletzt am
19.01 aus einer Haft im Zusammenhang mit
einem ehrlichen
Körperverletzung in Billwerder entlassen
wurde
die Staatsanwaltschaft Itzehoe
bestätigte dass der 33-Jährige schon
einmal wegen einer Tat mit einer
Stichwaffe in Erscheinung getreten und
zu einer Haftstrafe verurteilt worden
sei Motive und Hintergrund der
messeattacke von Brokstedt sind noch
unklar einen terroristischen Hintergrund
halten die Behörden für unwahrscheinlich
zur Innenpolitik einen Dauerstreit in
der Ampel ist heute Thema im
Koalitionsausschuss FDP Verkehrsminister
Wissing will ja neue Fernstraßen und die
ähnlich schnell planen und genehmigen
wie Schienenprojekte und das sehr zum
Ärger der Grünen denn Deutschland hält
im Verkehrssektor seine Klimaziele nicht
ein
2022 war dort ein CO2-Ausstoß von 139
Millionen Tonnen erlaubt tatsächlich
waren es noch vorläufigen Berechnungen
etwa 150 Millionen Tonnen also 11
Millionen mehr dazu jetzt Christiane
hübscher
der Weg zueinander ist mal wieder weit
zwischen Grünen und FDP völlig verhakt
im Streit um verkehrs- und Klimapolitik
muss beim Treffen im Kanzleramt am Abend
eine Lösung her im Kern geht es darum
Deutschlands Infrastruktur auf lng-tempo
zu bringen so wie das flüssiggasterminal
in Wilhelmshaven in nur fünf Monaten in
Betrieb genommen wurde so hätte es die
Ampel gerne andernorts auch im
Koalitionsvertrag heißt es beschleunigt
auf den Weg bringen und mit hoher
politischer Priorität umsetzen wolle man
systemrelevante Bahnstrecken
Stromtrassen kritische Brücken
und genau da beginnt der Streit zwischen
Grünen und FDP denn Verkehrsminister
Wissing will auch neue Autobahnen
beschleunigt planen und bauen die Straße
ist immerhin noch der wichtigste
Verkehrsträger den wir haben wir
transportieren beispielsweise 3,7
Milliarden Tonnen jährlich auf der
Straße und 370 Millionen Tonnen auf der
Schiene die grüne Umweltministerin hält
seit Monaten dagegen mit neuen
Autobahnen erreiche man keine Klimaziele
was ich nicht für sinnvoll halte ist in
Zeiten der Klimakrise und des Arten
Aussterbens zu sagen dass der Neubau von
Straßen wichtiger wäre als Klimaschutz
oder auch der Naturschutz eine solche
Achsenverschiebung im Umweltrecht die
hielte ich für falsch auch Umwelt-
mehr Platz für Güter und für Personen
auf der Schiene das ist in überragendem
öffentlichen Interesse und nicht der Bau
neuer Autobahnen 140 dringliche
straßenengpässe gibt es in Deutschland
ein Kompromiss könnte sein nur diese
beschleunigt anzugehen im Kanzleramt
wird mit einem langen Abend gerechnet
da sitzen sie also jetzt gerade die
ampelparteien im Kanzleramt es gibt
Streit zwischen FDP und Grünen die Ampel
braucht jetzt eigentlich dringend eine
Einigung Theo unbedingt denn im Grunde
gehört das ja nach den ganzen
kriegsthemen der vergangenen Tage zum
eigentlichen Kerngeschäft dieser
Koalition der Streit entzündet sich an
der richtigen Auslegung des
Koalitionsvertrags also wo will die
ampelplanungsbeschleunigung erwirken wie
viel Klimaschutz und wie viel
Erleichterung für die Wirtschaft hat
eigentlich Vorrang und gilt das auch wie
die FDP fordert für den Bau neue
Autobahn der Autobahnbau ist da im
Grunde ein stellvertreter-thema und da
ist der Streit auch so zäh und so
erbittert einerseits liegt der
Verkehrsbereich von Volker Wissing wir
haben es gerade gehört beim Erreichen
der Klimaziele weit hinten andererseits
fällt die Wirtschaft im internationalen
Wettbewerbsvergleich immer weiter zurück
und für die Liberalen zählt der schnelle
Autobahnausbau zu den wichtigen Punkten
einer beschleunigten Planung der
schnelle lng-
als Beleg dass ich das Land doch
schneller bewegen kann als gedacht heute
Abend wird eben darüber gestritten wie
und wo wir sind gespannt auf das
Ergebnis danke für die Einordnung Theo
call nach Berlin
sensible Daten verschlüsselt Freigabe
nur gegen Lösegeld so erbeutete ein
internationales hacker-netzwerk rund 92
Millionen Euro jetzt ist es mit Hilfe
von Ermittlern aus Deutschland und den
USA zerschlagen worden ein großer Erfolg
denn auf das Konto der Hacker sollen
mehr als 1500 Angriffe auf Unternehmen
und Organisationen weltweit gehen
darunter sind auch Geschädigte aus
Deutschland Andreas linke berichtet
Schwachstellen in der IT von Firmen
Behörden Organisationen haben Sie
gezielt ausgenutzt die Software dafür
lag auf einer Plattform genannt Hive die
ist seit heute lahmgelegt sagt
US-Justizminister Garland das Netzwerk
hat mehr als 1.500 Opfer gefunden seit
Juni 2021 in diesen Attacken nutzen
internationale Verbrecher Schadsoftware
für Schlüssel die IT-Systeme und
verlangen sozusagen Lösegeld
eines der betroffenen Unternehmen in
Deutschland war wohl der
Elektronikkonzern Media Markt etliche
Millionen Euro lose Geld soll er gezahlt
haben doch die entscheidenden Hinweise
fanden Reutlinger Polizisten nach einem
Angriff auf eine kleinere Firma und die
haben einfach nicht locker gelassen bis
sie den berühmte rote Pfade gefunden
habe und an dem Handy angefangen diesen
Fall aufzuholen und dann mit
internationaler Zusammenarbeit haben wir
versucht das gesamte Netzwerk weltweit
aufzudecken
die Plattform ist lahmgelegt aber ob der
Erfolg dauerhaft ist bezweifeln
IT-Experten
das ist jetzt erstmal nicht so ein
großer Schlag da hat man quasi dem Dieb
den Dietrich weggenommen aber der wird
sich jetzt ganz schnell neuen bauen und
dann ist er in zwei drei Monaten wieder
da
weltweit beginnt die Suche nach den
Hintermännern und auch da haben die
Behörden noch viel Arbeit vor sich
kommen wir jetzt zum Tarifstreit bei der
Deutschen Post da macht die Gewerkschaft
weiter Druck tausende Mitarbeiter waren
heute wieder im Warnstreik etwa 450.000
Pakete und 1,7 Millionen Briefe blieben
liegen die Gewerkschaft verdi fordert
15% mehr Lohn die Post hält das für
nicht erfüllbar
im Nahen Osten eskaliert die Gewalt
wieder die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde will jetzt die
Zusammenarbeit mit Israel in
Sicherheitsfragen stoppen hintergrund
ist ein Einsatz der israelischen Armee
in Genie investuord an Land dabei wurden
mindestens 9 Menschen getötet mindestens
20 wurden nach palästinensischen Angaben
verletzt Israel begründete die Razzia
mit Informationen über einen unmittelbar
bevorstehenden Terroranschlag dabei sei
es zu einem Feuergefecht mit militanten
Palästinensern gekommen
inmitten der Turbulenzen rund um die
Twitter Übernahme von Elon Muskat sein
Elektroauto Konzern Tesla 2022 so viel
verdient wie nie zuvor das Unternehmen
steigerte den Gewinn gegenüber dem
Vorjahr um 128 % auf umgerechnet 11,5
Milliarden Euro der Ausblick für 2023
ist durchwachsen mask erwartet ein Zitat
schwierige Rezession in den letzten
Monaten hat der Tesla die Preise seiner
Autos um bis zu 20% gesenkt um den
Verkauf anzukurbeln
für viele kam es dann doch überraschen
nur das ging schnell Nieselregen der
Straßen in gefährliche Eisflächen
verwandelte die Folgen Unfälle von
Norddeutschland über die Mitte bis nach
Süddeutschland und überforderte
Notaufnahmen Christian Volk
Massenkarambolage auf der A3 im
Landkreis Aschaffenburg 500 Meter
Fahrbahn plötzlich komplett vereist
insgesamt krachen hier 24 Fahrzeuge
ineinander 12 Menschen werden verletzt
zwei mussten mit dem
Rettungshubschrauber ins Krankenhaus
gebracht werden rund 300 km nördlich das
Marienhospital in Osnabrück hier wollten
die Rettungswagen im Minutentakt an mehr
als 80 verletzte nur durch Glätte
Unfälle so dass quasi zu jedem Zeitpunkt
bis jetzt etwa drei bis viermal so viele
Patienten wie sonst üblich in unserer
zentralen Notaufnahme sind
das Verletzungsmuster
verbundgemischt von Verletzung der
oberen unteren Extremitäten
beckenfrakturen also das komplette
Programm sozusagen viele Brüche mussten
dringend operiert werden die
Klinikleitung reagierte ein weiterer
OP-Saal musste her alle ursprünglich
geplanten Operationen wurden abgesagt
auch in der Nacht bleibt die Lage in
weiten Teilen Deutschlands angespannt
der Deutsche Wetterdienst war nahezu im
gesamten Land vor glatten Straßen
jetzt zum Sport Sven die Medaillenträume
für Deutschland Handballer die sind zwar
geplatzt aber das Turnier ist ja noch
nicht zu Ende ja stimmt denn trotz der
deutlichen Niederlage im Viertelfinale
gegen Olympiasieger frankreich hat das
junge deutsche Team noch zwei Spiele um
sich zumindest Platz 5 zu sichern auch
das wäre ein Erfolg doch zunächst galt
es die Enttäuschung hinter sich zu
lassen
mit dem Flugzeug ging es für die
deutsche Mannschaft heute Vormittag aus
Polen in die schwedische Hauptstadt nach
Stockholm wo ab morgen die Spiele um die
WM-Plätze 5 bis 8 stattfinden wir haben
leider eine kurze Nacht gehabt nach dem
späten Spiel gestern der frühen Abreise
heute ist es viel passiert deswegen war
sicherlich auch die Möglichkeit den
Gedanken auch mal ein bisschen woanders
hin zu lenken die zweite Halbzeit gegen
Frankreich ich möchte dass dab-team
schnell vergessen machen zu viele Fehler
und vergebene Würfe haben gezeigt
Deutschland zählt im Handball aktuell
nicht zur Weltspitze im Duell gegen
Ägypten wird es darum gehen ob
Deutschland am Sonntag um Platz fünf
oder sieben Spielen Ägypten haben wir
jetzt auch leider im letzten
Pflichtspiel beim Viertelfinale bei
Olympischen Spielen in Tokio dann auch
verloren das heißt da ist gewisse
Rechnung auch zu begleichen für unsere
Nation ob die Revanche gelingt zeigt
sich morgen Nachmittag
somit der Sport Tag eins der skeleton WM
in St Moritz mit den jeweils ersten
beiden von vier Läufen bei den Männern
und Frauen während die Männer patzten
gab es bei den Frauen eine positive
Überraschung WM debüttantin Susanne
Kreher aus Bärenburg ließ zu Halbzeit
mit fast 14 Vorsprung von und hat damit
beste Aussichten auf eine Metall gibt
Titelverteidigerin Tina Herrmann liegt
auf Rang 5 die Leute drei und vier
morgen bei uns im ZDF ab 14 Uhr 15
und das deutsche parateam ist bei den
alpinen Skiweltmeisterschaften auch im
Riesenslalom erfolgreich Annalena
Forster gewann in ihrem vierten Rennen
bereits die dritte Goldmedaille auf
ihrem monochi in der stehenden Klasse
sicherte sich Anna-Maria Rieder Silber
das tolle Ergebnis komplettierte Andrea
Rothfuß mit dem Bronze Rang
tolle Erfolge das war es vom Sport ich
danke dir Sven und ich Wagen jetzt mit
ihnen noch einen Blick in einen Känguru
Beutel wo sich dieses good fellow
baumkänguru Baby zum ersten Mal zeigte
seine Geburt im Chester so in England
ist eine absolut seltene Sache die
Mutter scheint mächtig stolz und im Zoo
ist man das natürlich auch denn die
Tiere leben normalerweise im
Bergregenwald und sind stark gefährdet
sehr süß
weil schon so viele Glätte und Fälle
gegeben hat heute Nacht wird wieder
glatt also schön vorsichtig bleiben mehr
zum Winterwetter gleich von Katja
hornefer um 21:45 Uhr empfehle ich das
heute journal mit Christian Siebers
sowie von uns danke und noch einen
schönen Abend für Sie
[Musik]